so tulsey gabbard finally announced he's
quitting the Democratic party and uh
obviously you know everybody saw this
coming I'm glad she's come out and
announced it I'm glad she's calling out
what she is calling out but I'm just
going to come out and say it before we
get into all the news I think it's uh
it's a little too late I'm a big fan of
Tulsi obviously you know I supported her
in her presidential run but uh too
little too late the bigger impact would
have been if in the 2020 race she came
out and said exactly what she's saying
now instead she endorsed Joe Biden and
uh I correct me if I'm wrong but she was
standing next to Biden during his
inauguration is what I was told is that
what happened so anyway
I think it's good that she's coming out
it's good that she's calling it out and
now a bunch of Republicans have come out
and said more are going to come out and
say the same thing but you know it does
feel a little bit late so we'll talk
about that that seems to be the big news
Republicans are cheering for this we
have a couple other big stories
Republicans are suing the Biden
Administration for collusion with big
Tech and censoring people's speech on
social media that's that's big for
obvious reasons and then a really crazy
story Elon Musk is reportedly turning
off starlink in parts of Ukraine after
talking with Vladimir Putin and now
they're claiming Vice has published a
story that Elon Musk talked with Putin
beforehand which Elon Musk is saying is
fake news but it's all just getting
absolutely insane so we gotta we got to
talk about this and I really I want to
talk a lot about
people who are leaving the Democratic
party and I think the big issue here is
the Democratic party has become the
party of the wealthy Elites conservative
news outlets say it moderate news
outlets say it leftist news outlets say
it and even Democrat establishment news
outlets say it so at what point do
people just recognize Tulsi is right
when she says it's a cabal of War
monitoring warmongering woke Elites so
we'll talk about all that but before we
get started my friends head over to
timcast.com to become a member and
support our work directly as a member
you'll get access to the uncensored
members only show we're gonna have one
of those up for you tonight at 11 PM you
don't want to miss it they sometimes get
a little spicy we swear a lot but it's
good fun not really family friendly and
you'll be supporting our journalists
directly so everybody who's writing
stories all day every day they rely on
you as members supporting our work so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us to discuss this and so much
more is Kathy Barnett hello everyone
thank you so much for having me on
absolutely thanks for coming who are you
oh wow who am I
I am a mom a a wife and I love my
country most people would know me I just
finished a brutal uh very competitive uh
Senatorial race and the primary for
Pennsylvania and uh now I am looking for
every opportunity to continue to push my
values right on well thanks for coming
this should be a lot of fun so much for
having me we've got Lou gradkowski of
course hey guys my name is we are
change.org and today I am wearing a Venn
diagram of where we are as Society
highlighting 1984 Brave New World and of
course Fahrenheit 451 highlighting
pretty much how we're screwed you can
celebrate our screwing by going and
getting the shirt on the best
politicalshorts.com because you do I'm
here thank you so much for having me I'm
also wearing a we are change shirt I
believe correct me if I'm wrong you are
one of yours isn't it attention is a
hell of a drug and then it's got your
social media apparati as pills and I
mean really like slot machines you know
they're just programming our brains with
this addiction quality I like the shirt
it's topical I was wearing it figured
I'd shout it out thank you Crossing in
case you didn't know and of course we
have search pressing all the buttons hey
guys I am here I gotta come in that was
low energy yesterday so I'll try and up
the energy today we're gonna we've got
to get like caffeine powder and pour in
his drink right before the show and then
it's like guys I'm here I'm searching
urging that joke's probably been made
before yeah I I feel like everyone's
heard these jokes before but then again
I have to realize it's me who's heard
all these jokes before not everyone else
so if you've got new ones please throw
them in the chat list or we can lean
into it and just you can sit back with
your eyes half close and be like
yeah I won't be the only one getting the
drug comments on the YouTube okay nice
hair by the way did I mention that way
yeah that's right I lost uh what was it
one of the comments I lost a fight with
the storage protector that's a new one
oh that's a good that's a good one yeah
that is because it's your name you know
yeah there you go all right let's jump
into this first story from timcast.com
Tulsi gabbard quits Democratic party
citing wokeness and anti-white racism
calls the party existential threat to
America and urges other party members to
join her that's just the story she gave
a speech saying nonetheless I can no
longer remain in today's Democratic
party it's now under the complete
control of an elitist cabal of War
mongers driven by cowardly wokeness who
divide Us by racializing every issue in
stoking anti-white racism who actively
work to undermine our god-given freedoms
enshrined in our Constitution and who
are hostile to people of faith and
spirituality who demonize the police who
who protect criminals at the expense of
the law
well that's good news as far as I'm
concerned but I do think she should have
come out and stated this a long time ago
absolutely right I mean finally welcome
to the nightmare that the overwhelming
majority of us have been living for you
know for quite some time probably on
steroids since 2016. so you know I don't
know a little too late I don't know but
I do believe that it is indicative of
what will happen to the Democrat Party I
think more and more you would see a lot
of people sane reasonable people who are
waking up to the reality of what the
left how the left has taken over the
Democrat Party this is one of the
craziest things that I've been hearing a
lot of behind the scenes that
something's been happening recently
where people are snapping and there's
like Mass red pilling going on I'm
hearing stories of like
you know from friends and this is not
like celebrities or famous people just
like hey my friend was all of a sudden
one day just came to me and said that
you know what's going on with war what's
going on with World War III Joe Biden's
doing all this and people are going from
in the dark to Red Pill just like very
very quickly and I I wonder if a lot of
it is when the news says nuclear war may
be coming you start to pay attention and
then when you do you go hey wait a
minute this Biden guy is actually really
bad I don't know if it's nuclear war I
think it's gas prices I think it's food
shortages that's a good point I think
it's those things for a lot of people I
live in a very woke quote-unquote uh
kind of area right outside of
Philadelphia the second uh the third
largest county in the state of
Pennsylvania the second wealthiest
county in the state of Pennsylvania
these people are very woke
um but however when you look at a lot of
these people are beginning to take that
red pill that they're watching what
happened to their children I think
education is going to be a real really
big issue for a lot of those Suburban
moms I was thinking that covid the
lockdowns or the shutdowns rather and
then the riots that didn't have much of
a military response or police response
was kind of opening but I think you're
right that it's gas prices I think your
prices yeah I think you know my
perspective is like why would a young
person and then you know obviously the
war is that's probably my personal bias
you bring up gas prices and I'm like oh
yeah yeah you're probably right some
some uh you know minimum wage
skateboarder guy who's trying to get
enough gas mustered up to go to the
skate park is probably saying what the
is going on and then he's looking it up
and being like why did Biden shut down
the Keystone Pipeline yeah I guess I
personally think it's the great reset I
personally think it's the build back
better agenda which coalesces into all
of these things when it comes to not
only actively being a war Monger but
also destroying the economy which I
think is being done deliberately here
here but but to go back into this topic
it does seem like the Democratic
establishment party is a sinking ship
they're expected to to lose a lot of
seats in this upcoming election and if
we remember Tulsi gabbard she was she
was seen as a rising star a few years
ago until she questioned the Syrian War
until she actually said hey maybe we
shouldn't be warmongers maybe we
shouldn't do regime change maybe we
shouldn't be financing Isis and Al Qaeda
inside of the Middle East and launching
a war on terror which of course is being
financed by our own money and when she
pushed back against a lot of the war
policies that's when the bigger attacks
against her happened by her own party
sort of it was really when she came out
against Hillary Clinton yeah that was
when the machine went real again yeah
yeah but she was again she was the first
combat veteran female running for
president of the United States you would
think just basically on those merits
that the Democratic party would lose
their mind and overwhelmingly illegal
support no absolutely not they didn't
believe in her they questioned her they
called her a Russian asset they
criticized her every step of the way
because she dared to say hey hey you
know know all these lies all these
bigger Banker bailouts all the ways that
you're being screwed over in America is
not okay and I'm going to stand up
against it she did successfully her her
Smackdown of Kamala Harris is absolutely
epic and she has done a lot of good when
it came to pushing the Overton window
starting conversations and debates even
though she was anti-gun endorsed Joe
Biden in the world economics nuclear
power and the world economic Forum even
liked her so much that they put up put
her up as Representatives now she of
course along with
um
Dan Crenshaw say that they were put on
there it would out there kind of consent
but but regardless still the world
economic Forum said hey this is a good
person we like we want to promote she
endorsed Joe Biden yeah I'm in luck how
are you gonna come out and say the
party's been taken over by a cabal of
warmongers when you endorsed one of the
principal warmongers don't tell me Tulsi
didn't know about what Joe Biden was
doing in the early in in the early 2010s
with the Iraq War his brother is getting
these lucrative contracts she like
there's no way she is unaware of what
Hunter Biden was accused of doing the
laptop stuff so I can I can respect if
you know behind the scenes she's trying
to be tactful and try and still remain
in the Democratic party to try and bring
people into it who might actually be
sane as to and cognizant of what's going
on but I kind of just feel like it's
2022 we're two months out not barely
from uh just just about two months out
from the from 2023 and Tulsi is coming
out saying I'm quitting the Democratic
party and it's just like yo if you came
out in October of 2020 and said all of
this exact same stuff like I will not
endorse a warmonger like Joe Biden we
may have gotten Donald Trump and we
would not be at War right now yeah and
she's also a member of the counts on
Foreign Relations which should spark up
a lot of eyebrows but uh there's a lot
of other scuttlebutt behind the scenes
talking about her potentially joining
Donald Trump her potentially joining
DeSantis and running with them for these
upcoming uh presidential elections so
there's a lot of scuttlebutt about her
positioning herself to be more
politically relevant and be able to run
on a party ticket that would Galvanize a
lot of the Working Class People because
but at the end of the day even though
you know World economic Forum endorsed
to see a farm member and endorsed Joe
Biden anti-gun she still does talk about
a lot of important issues that do uh
push the Overton window that do start
conversations that I think are important
all right I'm gonna say this everybody
deserves to evolve even you know Jack
Huger of The Young Turks he supported
defunding police today he says it's a
losing idea and it's a bad idea and he's
right and I and I commend commend him
for realizing the mistake he made
previously and now coming out and saying
you know what defund the place is a bad
idea I still think it's important to
point out Tulsi gabbard was very very
wrong in 2020. in this article from NBC
News and uh Tulsi gabbard ends
presidential run endorses Biden she said
it's clear that Democratic primary
voters have chosen Vice President Joe
Biden to be that per to be the person
who will take on President Trump in the
general election I'm confident that he
will lead our country Guided by the
spirit of Aloha respect and compassion
and thus help heal the divisiveness that
has been tearing our country apart
uh an announcement she noted that you
continue her military service but anyway
to go back to that quote she was wrong
Joe Biden has has and that speech where
he came out and called Maga Republicans
an existential threat to this country
did the exact opposite so this is just
Tulsi being very very very wrong
and if she came out back then and said
Joe Biden is divisive Joe Biden is a
threat to this country and we should not
be supporting him she didn't she
wouldn't even have to come out and
endorse Trump she can just be like I
will not endorse a man who was who is
vice president to an Administration that
blew up children in the Middle East and
for what reason couldn't tell you War
Empire regime change she'd probably just
say regime change but respectable
instead she actually and this blew my
mind endorsed Joe Biden while
campaigning on ending regime change War
it's like what do you think the Obama
Administration was doing with Joe Biden
there as vice president and now here we
are closer to war than ever so go ahead
no no but that's what's expected right
once you are um once you are not going
to win a particular uh race then the
party expects you to just line up and do
as you're told just take one for the
team and A lot of people do that without
uh of just doing what others expect them
to do I find it to be very inauthentic
uh and and authenticity was you know a
huge part of it was something that I was
very intentional about at the very
beginning of my race is to remain true
to those values that brought me into the
Republican party when I was a junior in
college from the Democrat Party to be
authentic to those values that would
cause me to want to run in the first
place because I earnestly believe we're
about to lose our country I don't
believe that that's hyperbole I believe
things are have gone very wrong
um and we need something very different
so for her to come out and support uh
Joe Biden in 2020 that is what is
expected of people and you know and and
to be completely honest that's what
plastic politicians do you get dragged
through the mud but then once it's all
over everyone expects you to shut up
line up do as you're told and just go on
but I wanted to go back to something you
said earlier about you know the fact
that uh you know that she's a woman
she's this she's there she checks off
all the boxes the Democrat Party should
have been in love with her that only
works if you also Follow The Narrative
but if you have your own mind your own
thoughts and your own opinion I don't
care how many boxes you check off I mean
look at me I'm black I'm a woman I grew
up dirt poor on a pig farm in Southern
Alabama underneath a rock you would
think the Republican Party the Democrat
Party would be like we love her you
would think that Republican
establishment would be like praise the
Lord now we have a fighting chance to
stoke some enthusiasm in our party but
if you don't follow the narrative
and the script it doesn't matter how
many boxes you check off they don't want
to have anything to do with it yeah put
it simply if you're not a controlled
puppet you're not going to get any play
and support by The Establishment but I
also want to talk on either side I
wanted to ask you what your permians
with your understanding of politics do
you think this move is highlighting
maybe something bigger maybe a bigger
move between a potential 2024 run do you
think something's happening behind the
scenes what do you think Tulsi is doing
here no one does anything in this
industry because it's the right thing to
do
if you think people in this industry do
things because it's the right thing to
do solely because it's the right thing
to do
that's not how this works yeah I don't
want to call it a publicity stunt but
she she coincided this uh announcement
with the announcement of her new show
the Tulsa show and on episode I'm not
sure I think it's on YouTube and okay
and uh an episode of Joe Rogan's podcast
that she just went on I just saw an ad
for that today so this was very planned
that she's probably been thinking about
this for a long time but she has been
taking you know little red pills at the
little red pills at the little red pills
for some time now right um now I don't
believe now a lot of Republicans we get
excited when people throw us little
bones
um you know oh look she's moving to our
side so I never thought she was a
conservative or really a republican but
I have seen over some period of time of
her taking these little red pills and so
now she finally took enough of them
where she's saying I'm leaving the
Democrat Party I think I think that's
going to be endemic of what we see
happen across a lot of uh you know those
particular communities where Democrats
have basically have taken people for
granted their vote for granted other
than the black community I think the
black community would probably be the
very last people to come off the
Democrat Plantation I think you're going
to see more and more Hispanics leave the
Democrat Party I think we're already
experiencing that and I think there are
a lot of sane repo Democrats who are
going to come off unfortunately I think
those who
share my Hue and complexion I think
we're probably going to be one of the
last why do you think it is that uh you
said you said the black community would
be the last to leave the Democratic
party what do you think that it is yeah
you know I mean even during the
Republican primary I spent a lot of time
in the black community you know I spent
a lot of time in democrat-controlled
communities and we would bring our
laptops with us every single time we
were going to one of these communities
and we were actively changing people's
registration from Democrat to Republican
one of the things I saw is that there is
truly just a lack of awareness I think
again I think things like gas prices
brings it home to people's kitchen table
and now they're paying attention to it
but other than that real quick did you
see that video out of Florida where the
two black guys are looking at the gas
tanker coming after the hurricane and
the guy's like I'm voting for DeSantis
and I'm a Democrat he's got he brought
the gases on the matter let me tell you
when I walked into black communities
um you know in 2020 when we were having
all these black lives matter Riot
rallies I started I was running for
congress that was my first time jumping
into the political frame I'm now in a
general election I started attending
black lives matter rallies no one would
invite me I would just walk up on stage
take the mic and say yeah I'm black what
are you gonna do about it and I would
say my name is Kathy Barnett I'm a
republican now get out of your emotions
and I will begin to talk to black people
about right where they're standing black
people want exactly what everyone else
wants we want Safe Streets we want good
schools we want good jobs right we don't
want to defund the police black people
never came up with that idea a white
Democrat living behind a gated community
came up with the idea of defund the
police black people never come up with
that the problem is there's a Litany of
them but one that we can control is the
fact that Republicans don't go into
those communities for a variety of
reasons we don't go in we don't compete
we just leave it as a far gone illusion
that they're going to vote for Democrats
what I did during the primary uh
this primary that I just went through is
I started going into black communities
changing every single time changing
their voter registration from Democrat
to Republican they are open it's just
they're very unaware of the reality you
mean you'd go in and talk to them about
it and then they would decide to switch
and then they would decide right so I
would go into these predominantly black
communities or I would go to an
environment where I knew we were going
to be bringing in a lot of black people
who were Democrats and I would stand up
sometimes I would have 30 minutes to
speak with them the other 30 minutes we
will be changing voter registration from
Democrat to Republican every single time
I would clear the room and I would get
all of these people to change their
voter registration why I'm not going in
plastic I'm not going in with canned
speeches I'm talking about right where
they're living they want their children
not to have to duck and Dodge bullets
just to get into their classroom they
want exactly what everyone else wants we
just got to go in and we have to we have
the more compel story we just have to
have the nerve to go in and do it how
did the white hipsters at the BLM rally
respond to you are you saying get out of
your emotions oh my goodness let me tell
you every single time I had my own rally
outside black lives matter would show up
every single time and there was not one
black person in the butt
I mean it is nothing I mean these are
some of the most racist and that's not a
word I throw around at all I'm very
careful about it but I found more
resistance and more hate from these
Progressive leftists I don't even want
to call them Progressive just these
leftists Democrats um you know trying to
tell me what it means to be black I mean
you know just very bold and very in your
face and I found them to be very nasty
um yeah so I do I think I found them to
be very nasty racism is so Insidious
because even when people are like trying
to give you compliments and be nice
racist leader like black people are so
beautiful like it's like dude leave the
the racism at the door talk to me like a
person yes but this is what the left
does there's a Yale study which I'm sure
you you saw right that Democrats talk
down actually there's there's two
different ones one is Democrats as a
political party uh they they lower their
vocabulary level when speaking to
minorities and liberals in general talk
down in the same way conservative
politicians and conservatives don't do
this yeah so did you see that that one
years ago yes I did I'm sure you've
experienced I think it was a couple
years ago yeah let me tell you something
I mean
every time I walk into a room they'd be
like oh she speaks so well
you speak so well right I mean I never
saw anyone say that to another white
person but it was always kind of pointed
at me oh you oh you speak so you speak
English really well like yeah I'm an
American isn't that what Biden described
Obama as yes right
so he did I remember that wow yeah Biden
said he and he went on and on about it I
know right like really good tea but but
I think yeah but I think Biden
explicitly said about him being black
yeah I think I'm looking it up right now
one of the texts he said was that he was
articulate and clean yes that's the word
you're so articulate and you know I mean
yeah you know I mean but that's just a
part of the issue I mean like that's you
know like that's something you can just
kind of give people a pass on but when
you look at the policies of the Democrat
Party every time I want to drive again
I'm on the I'm um my county of bucks uh
Philadelphia when I want to go into
center city of Philadelphia I take the
street versus the freeway um just so I
can get you know familiar with the
different areas and it just really rubs
me raw when I know I just drove into the
black community you drive from one
Community to another Community to
another community and you get into the
black community and it's trash
everywhere it's liquor stores everywhere
it's mattresses multiple mattresses just
sitting on the sidewalk it's very
irritating and so Democrats policies
they are showing up in some of the most
horrific ways primarily in Republic and
Democrat in Black communities I will not
read that quote from Joe Biden I'm sorry
you guys someone someone else that gets
to read it I'm not reading it who wants
to read it I'll read it I mean so read
the full thing the Biden famously says
uh Biden famously said in what is this
in the New York Observer I gotta get
that glare off the screen quote I mean
you got the first Biden says mainstream
African-American who's articulate and
bright says Joe Biden and clean and a
nice looking guy I mean that's a
storybook man what's the storybook that
a black guy's cleaned up Joe racist
freak I love you man I'm just saying
leave the racism at the door I respect
how you kept breaking the quota by
saying
I'm the one excuse me you don't make
that clipped out but I mean it's amazing
that he said that he had to apologize
for it but this to me
scientific studies showing that
Democrats talk down to black people that
they they they they they use lower grade
language like that says everything well
listen Democrats hated me and the reason
why they hate me is because I don't need
them I don't need them to pay my bills I
don't need them to help me with anything
all I need them to do is get out of my
way right and so I mean and that and
that was the reality that was my my
reality my experience of just running
um all across Pennsylvania but again
that was when I was in a general
election in 2020 now I came into a
primary election in 2022 and now I'm
running as a republican in a Republican
primary and let me just tell you the
issue is not just with the Democrat
Party we do have this thing called a una
party in our country uh and they are and
the Republic I mean Democrats cannot do
half the things they're doing if
Republicans in the establishment the
elites within the Republican Party the
machine was not complicit right don't
play ball what do you think about
Democratic policy has altered the way
you were saying that when you get to the
black community of Philadelphia that
there's trash on the street and yeah why
what do you think policy wise is caused
that specifically it's a broken culture
I mean you know and I would say to I
would go into again you know these
predominantly black communities
especially during the black lives matter
Riots of of 2020 and I would ask them I
mean you would be hard-pressed to find a
republican anywhere in leadership right
the only ones who were in leadership in
these predominantly black communities
were Democrats and so you can't look at
Republicans and say oh it's your pro
it's your fault that my trash don't get
picked up it's your fault that we have
these particular school systems that are
failing time and time and time again
which party is constantly saying they
don't want school choice they don't want
to give parents the ability to take a
voucher and if your school is not
competing and not providing your
children what they need then you have as
a parent because you know your child
better than you as a parent can take
that voucher and then take your child to
a school where your baby will success
where your baby will succeed which party
is is is working against that policy
Democrats are working against that just
to kind of bring things into highlight I
wanted to really get your perspective
because other than just failed
Democratic policies what do you think is
mainly responsible for uh you know areas
like Philadelphia for predominantly
black areas to be in the current
situation that they are right now yeah
what's the driving Focus who's
responsible I mean who's responsible I
mean well let me for me I always start
with myself right I mean I was a
Democrat uh I grew up I mean I grew up I
mean I grew below the bottom wrong of
the economic ladder I grew up on a pig
farm in Southern Alabama I grew up in a
home with uh no running water uh no
installation an outhouse in the back and
a well on the side when I say poor we
couldn't afford the other oh we were
just po but no one ever told me I was a
victim right we didn't have much but I
saw my grandparents wake up early go to
bed late taking care of their family
taking care of their Community right and
no one ever told me I was a victim and
so I went on to get an education I went
on to get married to have to wait till I
got married before I started having
children so you can learn these
particular things so before we start
saying oh it's the white man's fault or
oh is that black man's fault or oh it's
these people fault I always want to get
the mirror and put it up in my own face
and say what can I do with my life but
now once you get beyond that right
because I can only control so much I'm
so grateful to God I think it's going to
become increasingly difficult for people
who were like me who find themselves the
way I once was underneath the rock I
think it's going to become increasingly
difficult for those people to begin to
climb their way out of that kind of
poverty and create a new life for
themselves I believe the policies I mean
you know when you listen to Jerome
Powell the Fed chair talk about
destroying demand in order to get
inflation in line what he means by that
the way you destroy demand is by
destroying people's lives and you
destroy people Lies by forcing them to
be fired right or creating an
environment where jobs are not hiring
but firing right and I think that that
kind of environment and that kind of
mentality and Leadership that we have
today who say instead of growing the
economy Me by opening up oil and
allowing ourselves to be energy
independent we don't have that kind of
mentality we have the kind of mentality
that's leading this country that says we
need to destroy Demand by destroying
jobs right and when you find someone
like myself who you know I mean how do
you get a job if there are no jobs that
there are no opportunities so I think
it's going to become increasingly
difficult for people who find themselves
at the bottom wrong of the economic
ladder to begin to create a new life for
themselves when uh when Tulsi Gabba came
out and said she was quitting the
Democratic party and that you know there
are cabal of Elites and warmongers I
pulled up the Washington examiner
conservative Democrats of the party of
the wealthy Elites unheard moderate
Centrist Democrats of the party of rich
white Elites then we pulled up Jacobin
socialist newspaper Democratic party
keeps getting richer and wider if the if
the right the center and the left are
all saying the same thing and it's still
not enough for people to realize this is
what the Democratic party is I then
pulled up vox.com which is establishment
corporate Democrat to the T the
Democrats have replaced the Republican
party as the party of the wealthy Elites
how is it that there are people who
still don't get it that they still think
that if you are poor and working class
vote for the rich people who don't care
about you and want you to be cannon
fodder so I want to say this there's a
shout out to all of our good gen Z fans
if you're gen Z and you support the
Democratic party then uh I'm proud to
let you know that you will be prized
cannon fodder when they reinstate the
draft for their war against Russia so
congratulations it will be you on the
front lines now if you are between the
ages of 18 and 25 and realistically we
may be looking at a year two out so
let's say 17 to 24. the best thing you
can do right now if you don't want to be
forced to join the military is probably
oppose intervening in these foreign
conflicts
I was thinking about like 1930 Germany
and when the Nazi party came into power
and a lot of the German people were just
like I don't like them but I love
Germany Germany Pro I'm pro-germany so
I'll support whoever's in charge at the
moment and I think a lot of people are
like on pro-america so I support the
president and this party but like you
really have a duty to revolt against
nasty corruption I I do think that Biden
putting his son in barisma that that
Ukrainian oil wow putting us on there
that's allow I mean he could have told
him he could have said no
um conflict of interest yeah maybe he
didn't put him there maybe he didn't but
but allowing that to happen is like what
in the hell we're not uh recusing
himself from any dealings with Ukraine
being like my son works for an energy
company there I can't be involved and
the war stuff with like no backing down
it's like if you don't find yourself
supporting a government that wants to
take you into a war because that'll be
you and your kids that have to die it's
not worth it just to get back to the
original conversation because I think we
were on some really good points here
from the question that I asked that you
kind of went on and to answer your your
question to him you know a lot of the
times when people are in in poverty they
have a lot of things to figure out they
have a lot of problems and then here
come these politicians promising hey
we're going to help you guys hey we're
going to give you this we're going to
make sure everything's free and
everything's going to be handled
everything's going to be glorious and
then of course they win the election
then they're like screw you we don't
even care about you and then we see that
pattern routinely every four years and I
think personally to to kind of add to to
what you were just talking about I think
globalization that destroyed this
economy and and took away a lot of
American jobs along with the destruction
of the Modern Man and family units is is
predominantly one of the biggest reasons
why people are impoverished why people
are going to continue be to be
impoverished and I I think a lot of
these policies are being done
deliberately in my opinion with the
subjugation of humanity I want to tack
on unlike 1930 Germany a lot of people
have woken up to the crap like you guys
were saying earlier in the show the red
pilling of America is now with this tax
hikes and you're learning about the
military industrial a complex the
liberal economic order all this like
information that's available on the
because of the internet in a lot of ways
I think that people are able to not
blindly follow the warmongering leader
yeah so much more information yeah I
mean but you know um go I'm kind of
going back a little bit more we're
ping-ponging over here but you know uh
most people Define poverty in dollars
and cents but they don't but if if if
poverty if curing poverty was nothing
more than a stimulus check than black
people among all people well you know
all of our issues would be solved right
when you when you begin to think about
all the aid and all the government money
uh you know that that certain
communities get so if money if dollars
and cents was all that was needed in
order to cure poverty then hey it'll be
you know it's simple and it would be
over because our government has has
um has given welfare to so many
different groups of people but it's more
than that right and it's a Brokenness
and culture right it's uh where where
we're bankrupt and culture and it's not
just a black thing any longer I talk
about it in my book that if you know I
my my book came out in 2020 and I was
kind of putting out this Clarion call
that if we don't get our head out of the
sand and pay attention to what our
leaders are saying this this bankruptcy
and poverty that we think are confined
and in certain communities are going to
begin to spread outside of those
communities and begin to impact
um our little Bungalows right and that's
exactly what we're beginning to see yeah
I want to jump to this story from the
Daily Mail Biden Administration sued for
censoring Free Speech lawsuit accuses
president Karine Jean-Pierre Mary
Poppins of disinformation and slew of
officials of a disturbing amount of
collusion with social media firms to
quash critical stories Republican
Attorneys General of Louisiana and
Missouri are behind the lawsuit it names
67 government officials or entities as
having worked hand in hand with social
media companies to censor stories and
elections over in the economy they're
seeking to depose key defendants and
will ask a judge on Friday this
egregious attack on our first amendment
will be met with an equally full-hearted
defense of the rights of the American
people Louisiana A.G Landry said so just
a moment ago in the previous segments
Kathy you were mentioning that uh
well I guess the gist of the idea is
people need to know what's really going
on they need to be able to challenge the
politicians they need to be able to
understand what's happening in their
communities but now you have more and
more evidence piling up the government
is actually working with Big Deck to
make sure people can't know what's
actually happening in their communities
yeah so when we talk about why it is
that a poor person would keep voting
Democrat it's because they are being
locked in they're they're locked in a
bubble where they can't get accurate
information it's becoming increasingly
harder now I do think with all that
being said we are still winning this
this cultural battle we're seeing you
know The Daily Show Trevor Noah's
quitting CNN's in a death spiral Brian
stelter's canceled all of these awful
narrative mongers smear Merchants are
being ousted losing their positions of
of of power and influence and regular
people are finding their voices through
the internet we what we see here is the
government desperate to make sure you
don't know what's actually going on
around and that's a problem that's a
problem right can you imagine if Trump
had had weaponized the FBI the media
Facebook and Google and how mines will
be blown right now you know people hair
would be on fire to be running through
glass pane windows right the world will
be coming to an end but it is I mean
it's so Un-American and I believe and I
believe it is um just so very dangerous
I mean think about the first five rights
of the um um of the First Amendment uh
freedom of speech freedom of religion uh
uh freedom to um Allure I'm forgetting
because I'm on television right now but
freedom of speech freedom of religion
freedom of the press freedom to uh
mobilize what's that no not mobilize
fully assembled that's one form of
mobilization radius of grievances yes
exactly right and now but when you go
you know it's all five of them but when
you go down all five of them you will
see how this particular Administration
has just trounced uh have pounced on
people's
um just basic fundamental rights right
freedom of speech I mean go out there on
Twitter and put in Monkey pox and see
what happens to you right like they're
shedding all of that kind of
conversation down talk about you know uh
covid and the vaccines or any of those
particular things and there are certain
sites that will shut your conversation
down altogether like uh what you call it
YouTube like YouTube exactly yeah right
I mean I go figure and so and then and
then you wonder why people are I mean
when you know when we when we were on
the campaign Trail for 13 months we were
traveling over 1500 miles every single
week and we were going all across
Pennsylvania and I mean I saw you know
and and the people are just amazing we
have some of the most amazing people
within the Republican party but I can
assure you people are stressed people
are like in little pressure cookers
right now right and then when you when
they want to express themselves and
speak out and talk about the various
issues that are concerning them and now
they're told what you can we're going to
suppress we're going to Shadow band
we're going to you know boots you off
all together together that is not
creating a healthy environment for our
country and that's just on social media
now you begin to talk about you know
inflation and gas prices and what's
going on you know on the precipice of
World War III all of these particular
pressures it's a lot yeah I think the
demoralization it leads towards mental
poverty like you were saying you never
felt like a victim growing up and
because of that you were basically
wealthy I mean you may not have money
you don't need necessarily money to be
have a wealthy State of Mind friends and
family and love and desire to create I
was loved I was loved I was cared for
and because of that you created
something great yeah and people that
have no faith or that are think that
they're victims and are living that
lifestyle May tend towards destroying
themselves or allowing themselves to be
destroyed I mean but think about it if
you're living in a culture where every
every time you turn around as a young
black man let's just say as a young
black straight man let's just say um
everywhere you turn you're being told
you're a victim you're being told you're
inferior you're you're being told that
you know that because you have white
skin you have privileges that my brown
skin does not provide me that somehow my
brown skin is barring me from a world
that your white skin gives you access to
can you imagine if that is your daily
diet morning noon and night how you will
show up in the world right and so and
that is the narrative you know regarding
the censorship stuff I feel like not
that states have revolted for less but
that like if you pressure people living
that they can't have normal
conversations in their daily life
they're going to tell you to screw
yourself and they're going to form their
own government and if 39 states in the
United States told the federal
government no more no no no you're not
going to censor us we live free in our
states the problem is if state
governments start censoring their own
people that's why we built a federal
government was to protect people from
States overreaching on their citizens so
that's the first time we've been in this
well that's basically Shea's Rebellion
is an example of the Massachusetts
Government just imprisoning people at
will bring it in the federal the federal
government can't actually pardon people
for State crimes no but it can it can
send in federal troops to make sure that
a state doesn't like the freedoms
violating the Constitution exactly
violating the Federal Constitution yeah
and um this is kind of the first time in
our history that we've had a situation
where people feel like the federal
government is infringing on their rights
more than their states and it's I don't
know tenably like you Luke you were
saying you feel like it's like this new
this order this change of order I'm not
sure how you phrased it earlier
um maybe it's just inevitably the the
liberal economic order the
american-led rules-based international
economy is fading away and and we're
just seeing like the struggling death
throws of uh but the thing is it's
that's not it because it's us it's the
people of the United States no no no
we're leading this thing the unit party
for the longest time was an elite class
uh look at the media for the longest
time if you wanted to be a journalist
you had to come from a rich family
because the companies were based in New
York City the big ones and if you wanted
to work there you had to be an intern
meaning you weren't getting paid or
you're getting paid very little and how
can you afford to live in New York City
getting paid very little your parents
paid your bills this was a well-known
problem in the media industry even up to
10 years ago and it probably is still a
problem in New York though it's probably
been alleviated to a certain degree now
we're seeing that regular little old
people can take a GoPro put it on their
monitor screen and talk for a few
minutes and eventually grow that into a
podcast where they have a voice
that's changing the game and this means
the establishment unit party is losing
that class-based control they've had for
the longest time and they had tried to
consolidate their power at the
corporation legalities or you can like
say hey you can't sue me you can't take
anything from me you got to take it from
that fake Corporation I built and then
they can move their corporation offshore
have bank accounts offshore and they're
basically the oligarchs running the UNA
party is this this wealthy corporatist
it's it's you know it's pretty simple
here tyrants can't roll if they can't
control information because people will
speak out against their tyranny and this
is exactly what they're doing and what
they've been doing I've been screaming
about this for many years now people
called me a conspiracy theorist people
called me a cook people said I was
insane I was crazy there's no way that
the federal government is involved when
it comes to censorship of big Tech
social media they're private companies
they get to decide and do whatever they
want themselves because they're private
entities let the free market speak and I
was screaming on the top of my lungs it
is not a free market it never was a free
market intelligence agencies helped
start up a lot of these major
corporations and on other hand who's
playing with their phone right it's
getting hot is that you or me I think
it's Kathy put the phone down ma'am
attention uh and and and truly truly
what is happening here is them saying
you know what we're gonna go after
comedians scientists Doctors medical
professionals politicians we don't care
we're just going to censor and shut
everyone up for our own personal benefit
because we want to control every aspect
of this existence including the thoughts
in your head and that right there is
just too much power for any individual
to have they should be sued out of town
they should lose their positions of
power because they were very
irresponsible with it and they're
endangering all of us by trying to
literally enact thought control so my my
concern is that even if they're sued and
they are totally legally you can't do it
anymore and they're like okay we'll stop
the private companies or private
companies they've got like the the prism
spy Network we know that they have like
secret spying networks that they'll just
do it anyway I mean that's my concern is
like de facto rule what how do we really
you need encryption you need
decentralized communication sources you
want to say something well no I was just
thinking um you know a lot of what is
about what is happening what will
continue to happen is that uh activists
will bypass the voting box uh and go
straight to corporate boardrooms it's
this little thing called ESG right
environmental social governance and it
is simply a way for uh the government
for activists and and some of those and
within the government who wants it you
can't get it passed in Congress so you
bypass the voting box and you go
straight into the corporate boardrooms
and that and now we see these um uh uh
these uh business Elites like Black Rock
State Street Vanguard and other and
Coca-Cola and other companies that are
using their leverage to force upon the
American people different uh uh
different American values right and so
you see that going on and on and on
again so now we're approaching the time
time when the federal government will
not be so you know
big government and and trying to impede
upon your uh personal rights or even
trying to usurp the the state government
they would just bypass all of that and
and use these large corporations and
that is what they're doing under ESG
they also have a thing called impact
investment which is a big buzzword 21st
Century Investments so they get
corporations that go to the board they
basically get the board to think a
certain way and then that's where they
put their money whether it's through
charity or whatever into
you know events that they want to see
happen and or people that they think
will spread the message that they want
them to spread YouTubers things like
that absolutely well yeah well I mean
like like for example BlackRock State
Street uh Vanguard uh the three of those
asset managers they manage over 22
trillion dollars right and that is
larger than uh the United than America's
GDP so they manage more money than than
the wealthiest com uh country America
right and so that's a tremendous amount
of influence so when you look at just
these three
um asset managers alone they own 21 of
Exxon stocks and they leverage all of
that buying power to go in to kick off
three of their board members on exons
and replace them with three activist
board members right and and then you and
once they take over the largest of all
of the uh oil and gas companies now they
just use them as posters children as
they go to Chevron and mobile and others
and say if you don't do what we tell you
to do when it comes to stop drilling or
to adopt more or to try to transition
faster away from oil and into renewable
energy then we're going to do to your
company what we just did to the largest
uh company Exxon that's exactly what
they did and so they are literally not
only destroying the fiduciary
responsibility between and um the the
manager who manages the uh the
individual investors money so they're
messing up that relationship because if
you're managing my money your only focus
should be on maximizing my shareholders
well but if you're no longer focused on
maximizing my shareholders wealth but
now pushing a particular narrative now
you're changing traditional American
values and you're bypassing the voting
box to do it that's my concern with
doctors too because it used to be a
doctor to Patient it was like the
investor to the investor manager and
that was all they cared about was the
health of the patient now you've got I
don't know if BlackRock State Street and
Vanguard are on the boards of of
hospitals as well of uh insurance
agencies I wouldn't be surprised to find
out yes they are and so is it confirmed
three scope three is something that you
find in um in Chevron for example and so
what scope 3 is which is what these
activists are pushing it forces private
companies to become the Big Brother of
every other company in their supply
chain right so if you're Chevron you
should you should just be focused on
finding Investments to drill more oil
especially in a time that we find
ourselves right now but instead Scopes 3
says not only do you need to be
um green new energy compliant but that
insurance company that's selling you
insurance to protect your workers you
need to now play Big Brother to them and
make sure that they too are moving
towards doing everything they need to do
to be clean you're absolutely right on
the money and I would even say it goes
even bigger than private corporations it
happens to other countries like Sri
Lanka Sri Lanka of course we're going
along with the ESG score implementing
the ESG policies the world economic
Forum was like they're doing great and
amazing they're going to be the biggest
and brightest stars in the developing
world and what happened to Sri Lanka
they were deliberately destroyed by the
policies that they were extorted and
manipulated to implement that that
pushed diversity you know all these
issues diversity wokeness uh gender
equality all of that and then what
happened when they put in all the green
policies and all the policies that of
course it wrecked and utterly destroyed
their country and this wasn't an
accident this was done deliberately and
now the same policies that were tested
in Sri Lanka that were tested on the
corporations are being implemented
globally and are being introduced here
in the United States and we'll topple
the Western World from what I'm seeing
it wasn't a mistake no everything we're
seeing in Sri Lanka with the food riots
in the in the gas shortages and all that
that's the intended sequence they they
outright are saying it they're telling
Farmers not to farm they're saying oh
the farming is bad for the environment
so don't do it even though we're facing
a food shortage because of the war
they're saying they want to shut down
fossil fuels what do you think happens
take a look at Sri Lanka if that's the
country you want to live in by all means
keep on moving forward with these policy
plans but I'll tell you it's not the
conservatives the Libertarians and the
post-liberals who are going to be
dealing with it because these people are
getting out of cities it's going to be
the urban liberal who is oblivious
waking up one day and being like why are
there Marauders running through the
streets stealing everything why is there
no food and what do I do people in the
countryside aren't impervious because
the what happens is corporations will
try to sue the American people the
trans-pacific partnership with setting
it up so that corporations could sue the
American government if we weren't if we
were discriminating was the language
against their Oil Company whether we
weren't following ESG standards as
Citizens or we weren't buying their oil
and then the taxpayer has to pay for
that and the government will find Joey
baloney out in the middle on nowhere in
the woods and charge him taxes for some
corporation's agenda in Malaysia and how
do you escape from that other than
blatantly breaking the law citizen of
the world
like you're now a citizen of the world
right so so we are now responsible for
what happens in in another country I
mean when you think about these 87 000
new IRS agents who may or may not be
armed
um you know this is the world in which
we're about to wake up in and I agree
with you wholeheartedly this is not this
is very intentional none of this feels
organic right that it just happened upon
us in two short years I mean this had
this feels very intentional this has
been coming and building up for a very
long time some people say be before even
the UN 2030 Vision even before that
there was other visions and other
projects that were pushing forward the
same end goal but just back to the Sri
Lanka point because I think it's an
important one Sri Lanka had a 98 plus
ESG score
and they did everything when it came to
any energy policy domestic policy hiring
policies governmental policies they they
followed they followed and obeyed
because as they were the poorest country
that literally were extorted at the
barrel of a gun just like we saw with
economic Hitman uh with that amazing
book that detailed the Decades of U.S
actions uh against the developing world
the confessions of an economic event
sorry there uh great book detailed how
they were doing this now they're doing
this under a new uh disguise under a new
woke term it's called ESG as you were
bringing up and it's not just the
acquisition and the Takeover of
Corporations it's the Takeover of
countries they beta tested Sri Lanka now
they're going to be testing it on the
rest of the world
is basically the Chinese Communist party
for the West it is and when when you're
in when you're in China you'll start a
business at a certain point you need an
office for the Chinese Communist party
in your business that's what we were
told by some actress that's true it's
true so in the United States what
they're doing is ESG as the exact same
thing it is the ideological component
that all businesses must adhere to
giving some unified Authority control
over you your business and what you're
allowed to say or do did you conf you've
confirmed that BlackRock State Street
Vanguard they buy 18 to 22 percent of a
public company and they have a lot if
not they have so many publicly traded
companies they have like 18 do they then
put three board members on their board
is that like every time I'm not sure
about every time but that is uh exactly
what they did with Exxon
XI so again
Black Rock State Street Vanguard now
there are hundreds if not thousands of
these asset managers these are just the
top three and they manage over 22
trillion dollars of assets around the
world right and again that's larger than
the entire GDP of America so that so I
say that to say these people own a term
I mean they have a tremendous amount of
power and clout and leverage and
specifically to Exxon Mobil they own the
three of them 21
of uh of Exxon shares and so what they
did is that they worked alongside this
very small activist
manager I think it's called engine
number one and who had no clout to do
anything but engine number one put up
these three uh activists board members
and and BlackRock State Street Vanguard
they decided to come alongside engine
number one and to use their leverage and
their proxy votes to vote in those three
three board members right so they kicked
out three added three and Exxon Mobil
has gone woke you want to read can you
read can you read that one Ian okay but
this might be one it might be a
challenge where uh the whole thing the
whole thing the whole Blackness blurry
for me all right let me read it let me
read it okay BlackRock Inc is an
American multinational investment
company based in New York City founded
in 1988 initially as a risk management
and fixed income institutional asset
manager BlackRock is the world's largest
asset manager with us 10 trillion
dollars and assets under management as
of January 2022 BlackRock operates
globally with 70 offices in 30 countries
and clients in 100 countries BlackRock
has sought to position itself as an
industry leader in environmental social
and corporate governance ESG the company
has faced criticism for worsening
climate change its close ties to the
Federal Reserve System during the
covid-19 pandemic anti-competitive
behavior and its unprecedented
investments in China and you know what
I'll just add as the cherry on top
BlackRock just sounds like the name of a
villainous organization from a mission
impossible movie I have my BlackRock
right here it's called obsidian and I
believe that's where they got the name
is from the city in the Looking Glass no
there's a lot of occult symbology when
it comes to Blackrock Black Cube which
is also an Israeli intelligence private
Contracting agency there's also
religious aspects here uh you know
spiritual aspects like Mecca is a big
black case exactly so there's there's a
lot more uh reference to this than than
a lot of people realize
um black stone also this is all about
this black rock I don't know if it's
volcanic glass or what they're talking
what's Mecca what's the it's called the
kava Kaaba what's it made out of uh I
don't actually know but it's been there
for a while it's actually pretty it's
it's it's it's it's it's not the uh
you're talking about Mecca it's the
thing inside of it correct right all
right yeah the other thing is not
actually it's commonly misconstrued as
that's the outer thing but it's actually
just a small thing that's been inside of
Mecca for thousands of year pre-islam if
I'm correct I heard it was like a
meteorite or something yeah now we're
talking yes um regarding
anti-competitive behavior for BlackRock
I've read that BlackRock State Street in
Vanguard own each other and it's just a
subtly shares of each other now yeah I
would if anyone in the chat can source
that data for me and send it to me on
Twitter mines I'd love to have another
look at it this is like 10 years ago six
years ago when I was invest who owns
these companies I want to find the names
of the guys but it just turns out it's
other corporations and they well he's
the CEO Larry Fink founder the founder
but who owns it I don't know the CEO
doesn't even have to have a percent
aliens and when you ask people well what
is ESG no one really knows what ESG is I
mean it is he is it's a it's a huge
dichotomy between what they say it is
and how it's gonna revolutionize
capitalism and then there's reality of
what's actually going on right and it
gives more and more Insidious as you go
in when you look at the credit rating
agencies I mean they're making money
hand over fist BlackRock alone uh they
charge uh five times the fees for their
ESG awareness funds versus other funds
that are just you know just basic with
all kinds of companies in there but then
when you look at these ESG aware
companies that are when you look at
these ESG funds and you look at the
companies that are that are on the
inside of them BlackRock again one of
the largest ESG awareness funds uh 90 of
those companies and those awareness
funds are also in the S P 500 right so
what's the difference right but you're
charging five times the fee I want to
tell you why West Virginia is best
Virginia and why it is one of the best
states in blackrocks Wikipedia it is a
West Virginia Section Riley Moore the
state treasurer of West Virginia said in
June 2022 that BlackRock and five other
financial institutions would no longer
be allowed to do business with the state
of West Virginia because of their
advocacy against the fossil fuel
industry Moore said at a time when
energy demand is skyrocketing and
consumers are bearing the brunt of
General generationally High inflation it
makes absolutely no sense for financial
institutions to cut off Capital and
financing to these legal profitable
Industries simply because they don't
align with their radical social and
political agendas so good on you West
Virginia yeah and I don't wanna this is
when I was earlier talking about the
states revolting against the corrupt
government that's trying to censor them
it's more about the the corporations
that we should be focused on exactly
because again they are doing what would
never get passed in Congress so they are
by if you and I or if America wants to
change our values to where we just want
to Dish ditch uh fossil fuel and and you
know
who cares if the economy crashes let's
just all move down the path of
Renewables then we should be able to go
into a voting booth and we should just
vote in all leftists right who who say
that they just want to destroy America
energy if we want to say listen parents
do not control our children we want the
government to be able to control our
children if we want to start saying
listen it's all about social justice you
don't have to earn your your your title
meritocracy is out the window we should
be able as Americans to go into a voting
booth and vote those values into our
country but instead but that would never
pass because you will never get the
majority of Americans to say yeah we
just want to upend everything so what
they're doing is they're bypassing you
and I as voters to decide what kind of
country we want to live in and they're
going to these corporate board Elites
and they are now using their leverage
all of their money to go into these
corporations and say if either you align
with what we're saying about
environmental that's climate change the
S is
um
social which is which is wokeness which
is CRT transgenderism with your children
transitioning your children and then the
governess ESG the governess it is
actually I I liken it to the glue that's
bringing all of it together right the E
the S and the G and so they're going to
these corporations and they're saying
either you align with what we say uh you
need to have X number of women X number
of black people X number it doesn't
matter if they earned it doesn't matter
if they if they deserve it you just put
them on your in in leadership because we
say it that is what they're doing and
they're saying it to the boards of the
companies and is it just like if you're
not going to go down so then they'll buy
off like certain members of the board
and be like now that we have a majority
of the board paid off you better do what
we say or we're gonna [ __ ] kick you off
the board kind of thing and it's not
just that I mean like that's one of the
things that they did I mean like as an
example that's what they did to Exxon
they replaced three of the board members
of Exxon and they put in three very
liberal uh activists climate change
activists as board members on axon right
so that was one of them coming in and
and and kind of taking over the board
but another thing that these companies
get to do again they manage a tremendous
amount of of
um of assets and so one of the things
they can do is just underweight how much
of your assets they're gonna they're
going to put their money in right
um and so and if you're a publicly held
company and people are selling off your
stocks that's not a good thing you want
people to be buying your stocks right A
lot of these CEOs they're their bonuses
their their compensation is tied to
their stock value so they can so instead
of taking over your board they can
simply underweight you because you're
not aligning with their principles
they're pretty much they pretty much in
work like the mafia they come to you and
they're like you're going to do what we
say or we're going to steal money from
you and beat you down and destroy your
livelihood and then a lot of these
companies comply because they want a
good score they want to comply with
everything that they're doing but but I
think you're also wronging by just
calling them corporations they're not
just private corporations they are
entities that are working with the US
Federal Reserve printing money out of
thin air funneling it into Wall Street
with no accountability with no track
record with no transparency at all and
now when you have the coffers of the
Federal Reserve at your beck and call
you could do whatever you want you could
say hey we're going to invest money here
we're going to put money here we're
going to give this company here this
Corporation here all this money you want
some of it you got to go along get on
your knees and worship the altar of our
uh you know a rule that we're going to
be of course pushing on everyone and
it's even Beyond just even BlackRock
California mandated increased diversity
on their corporate boards that was a law
they had to comply so this was going
along with their policies that are being
implemented not through just economic
Force but also government Force as we're
seeing the same people responsible for a
lot of these policies coalesce and
Implement them in all aspects of life
you're right that calling Corporation is
not accurate they need new names for
these multi these I don't know megacorps
but then the word Corp is in there I'd
rather just focus call them something
unique when they've become I don't know
so prolific cabals cabals that's a good
way to put it legal cabals you said that
they underweight a corporation how does
that work if the BlackRock were to have
what are they they own 20 of the company
so how would they do that well just for
example like I said they have 22 just
those top three 22 trillion dollars
right and then they get to decide how
much of their money of your your money
because it's really your money it's not
their money you invest in one of their
funds right and so they're supposed to
have this fiduciary responsibility where
it's all about maximizing your
profitability and so they take your
money so I save their money but it's not
really their money it's your they manage
roughly 22 trillion dollars and so they
can decide where they want to put that
money and that's stakeholder capitalism
stakeholder Now define a stakeholder
right you're here in America and you're
you know busting you're hot my
grandfather he was a janitor I mean I
mean it was just you know and so he
could take his money and try to invest
and he wants to retire but instead of
investing along his values his
principles and investing for the purpose
of maximizing his few dollars so that
one day maybe he can retire send his
kids off to college they take that money
and they say well hey my stakeholder is
not you the shareholder older right my
stakeholder is I don't know climate
change and some remote part of Africa
right building roads or schools or
social justice and some you know some I
don't know in the Amazon somewhere so
it's very nebulous it's very um there's
a tremendous amount of ambiguity the SEC
has now gotten involved because there's
a lot of green washing where you have
people who are just saying they're green
or that they're ESG compliant just
because in essence is I I liken it to
designer label right ESG is nothing more
than a designer label and you want to
have that Designer label because now you
can charge more fees you look Chic
people want to invite you to the
Christmas party and because it's because
it's there's nothing good that's coming
out from this so how did we end up with
Dr Oz instead of you
well Dr Oz I mean he doesn't seem to
know anything about this he doesn't talk
about it it seems very generic you were
running you seem to be extremely
knowledgeable at all of these issues
internationally and domestically and and
and the people of uh Pennsylvania that's
the choice they get well let me just say
um again the people of Pennsylvania are
some of the best people I I mean again
13 months 1500 miles every single week
um the overwhelming majority of the
rooms I walk in I was the only black
person in the room and yet I felt like I
was their sister I felt like we were in
um that we had a meeting of the minds
and we were trying to fight and win our
country back I absolutely love the
people of Pennsylvania my heart grieve
you know just because I believe they
deserve good leadership I believe they
deserve people who were actually not not
just Pennsylvania but all of America my
heart Grieves for us we are living in
very serious time times and we have some
very unserious quote-unquote leaders
right now right and everybody seemed to
be lining their own pocket when you look
at Nancy Pelosi and her husband Paul
Pelosi what it seems what appears to be
some insider trading going on who knows
right and you see that time and time
again you see all this money going over
to Ukraine and no one can tell you where
the money is going but hey let's trust
them although Ernst young ranks Ukraine
in the top five most corrupt countries
in the world right but hey let's just
send over another you know 12 billion
dollars and if you don't do it you must
be a Russian sympathizer right you can't
have any honest dialogue about some very
serious things that are going on right
now and that is the reason why I ran I
am the most unlikely candidate just to
give some perspective I ran against you
know the you know my two main primary
opponents they spent when you look at
what they spent and the money from the
packs they spent 60 million dollars on a
primary race right I spent less than two
million dollars and all of it came from
the people but this is what you get by
13 months 1500 miles knocking on every
door I have no regrets I left it all out
there on the on on the road now the
people have chosen in large part because
Sean Hannity is a jackass can I say that
yes
amen hallelujah
the people were manipulated we were
going to win Sean Hannity is a jackass
but we already know that I don't think
that's a cuss word I was asking Jesus
about that on the way up here
is a donkey right it's another way of
saying donkey but he is I know um
but nonetheless uh we're now in a race I
am not on the ballot
um I am I will be walking in voting
Republican all the way down because God
knows fetterman is a hot mess and I
would never vote for him
um and I would encourage pennsylvanians
to do the same to walk in and not vote
for fettermen I would actually even say
Hannity is a status stooge and I
definitely agree with your sentiments
he's a puppet absolutely remember puppet
of the intelligence so for seven
different times he never once asked me
any of those riveting questions that he
wanted to ask in the last five days and
what you're saying about the ESG score
is the nail on the head it's one of the
most important issues that no one else
wants to really talk most important and
you covered it very very well which
which again a lot of people don't do
that and a lot of people are afraid to
talk about these issues so I commend you
for having the courage for doing so and
and speaking about these issues so
boldly but I just wanted to ask you
specifically what in the world do you
think Donald Trump was thinking
endorsing Oz over you what was going
through he said what's going on here
before you answer now y'all know I gotta
go back to Pennsylvania right so don't
get me in trouble with the people I look
forward to
um assuming we ever get the opportunity
sitting down with uh with former
president Trump I just saying to him now
when you made the terrible mistake of
endorsing Dr Oz Over Kathy Barnett did
you uh did you do it on purpose or were
you aware that it was a tremendous
mistake and you did it anyway
everyone agrees
agrees take you should not have endorsed
eyes everyone everyone's like at least
that's what I was told what would you
say to that
what did it well I was there and asked
what Hannity what did he do that in the
last he lied about you why really oh he
dragged me he dragged to your face no
he's a punk he of course he wasn't right
and I went on Twitter and I said well
since you have all of these riveting
questions I am um gonna you know I'm
gonna hold Monday 9 p.m uh come into
Studio you the other person you are
really you know in love with and helping
um it'll be two against one I'll come in
you can ask me all of these riveting
questions but that's not the point the
point is they looked up and they were
like oh my God this little black chick
is about to win and we can have that
right because what was done to me was
not and this is something for the
Republican party right to uh for for the
voters uh to pay attention to that I was
not dragged with these horrible lies
right calling me a black lives matter
um um
empathize yeah supporter that I'm a part
of black lives matter they would they
would uh get a picture of me and they
will flash a picture of me after saying
black lives matter or flash a picture of
me after saying black rioters right you
know of playing those really stupid
games and it wasn't the left who was
doing this to me it was my own party
which just shocked the world I mean I
know you know politics is dirty but
that's a whole nother level and what in
and you know I I I'm a conservative and
I think I don't think it was racist
necessarily although racism and elitism
feels a whole lot alike in today's
economy of things no one's going you
know no one came to my house and told me
to walk out and try to you know Lynch me
or anything like that that's real racism
right but this was really ugly it was
really nasty
um it wasn't just Politics as Usual
um and so but the Republican Party
I know they want us to be all about the
party and I recognize that it's such a
dichotomy for me because there's no way
on God's green earth would I ever vote
for a Democrat right and we live in a
two-party system so you're either voting
for one or the other and yet I you know
it was my values that brought me to the
Republican party with my values that got
me involved in these political races and
I do not believe I have to abdicate my
values in order to support the party I
think it's our business to beat the
party into alignment and right now we
have not just a cabal among ESG
corporate board members are cabal among
Democrats but we have it also within the
Republican party and if I could just say
one more thing
let me just throw this out here as well
I don't believe I believe I have a
tremendous amount of Hope by what I saw
in my race and my race in those last
five days we were about to win and I saw
over 330 000 pennsylvanians almost a
third of pennsylvanians came out and
voted for me right and they did so in
defiance of millions of dollars of lies
from people like you know Rick Grinnell
uh Greg Kelly uh Sean Hannity they
defied them they also defied all of the
Trump influencers who came out and said
don't vote for her they defied Donald
Trump himself and they still came out
and voted for me that gives me a
tremendous amount of Hope right that
people are not willing to just check
their brains at the door and just do as
they're told people are waking up
something which you said a little bit
earlier people are being red peeled and
they're recognizing something has gone
fundamentally wrong with how our nation
is being governed and we want different
the problem is that lost by roughly Five
Points and it was as a direct result I
believe of what you know uh you know
people who say they are conservative
people who say they are a part of our
party did to shove someone else down our
throat and so now we got to live with
that decision but I still have a
tremendous amount of Hope by what I see
how my race turned out and that people
just they refuse to be denied a better
option Hannity may as well have endorsed
fetterman
because Dr Oz is unrelatable and
unlikable and that gives fetterman a
huge Advantage look I've seen the videos
that fetterman puts out he's got health
issues he's got something you know
really really wrong with his neck I hope
he's okay I don't know what that is he
was always wearing it was the weirdest
thing he's in suits and he's wearing a
scarf and it's because he's got
something he's got something seriously
wrong I mean the man had a stroke but
you look at the videos and and Dr Oz
pronounces the name of a store wrong
that was this was a big big I don't know
what did he say was it Wegmans or
something Wegmans uh yeah I don't
remember what happened and then he was
like my wife's trying to make crudite
and it's just like who is is he trying
to pull Suburban white upper class photo
or something and then fetterman comes
out and he really tries to play up to
the to the Philadelphia you know working
class Democrat you know a good old boy
or whatever these are these are the guys
that showed up when the When Auntie was
trying to tear down the Christopher
Columbus statue this is a predominantly
Democrat City yeah that's what fetterman
is going for when Henry came out and he
tanked your campaign pain and then helps
prop up Oz He was basically saying I
hope Letterman wins listen fetterman is
horrid I mean horrible right I mean he
was horrible before the stroke now he's
horrible
with health issues a horrible person who
had a stroke right that's who he is
essentially I mean I mean just I mean
from the you know from his physical
appearance before the stroke his
physical appearance after the stroke
um you know his ideologies his thing you
know I mean the man chased down a black
man with a shotgun
what was that story what happened
exactly so like the black man was just
outside trying to get some exercise eyes
and just just jogging he claimed he
heard some gunshots so he grabbed a
shotgun went outside and there was a
black guy jogging and he chase after him
yeah crazy he just happened to see a
random black man running right and then
you know he drops his son off runs in
the house gets his his shotgun gets in
his truck barrels down on this black man
and holds him there with the shotgun up
to his chest until the police came right
and said oh you know I've been thinking
about I don't know um one of the school
shootings and you know and I thought I
heard a gunshot dude is is Saturday
morning nine o'clock in the morning it
was school's not in right and it was at
fireworks it was a very different sound
I I have absolutely no idea but this is
a horrible individual and he would make
a horrible Senator
um you know and my hope is that people
will wake up and yet at the same time I
have to say you know if we keep holding
our nose voting for the lesser of two
evils I mean you have to begin to ask
yourself as conservatives what are we
actually conserving we now have red flag
laws we now have 87 000 new IRS agents
who may or may not be armed who the IRS
has told to now start tracking
transactions of 200 or greater we now
have open borders I mean it's just a
Litany of things
um that we would that we were like you
know we don't want so at some point
maybe November 9th we'll be ready to
have a conversation about what we need
to do to make sure that our own uh
Elites within the Republican Party Don't
tank the next conservative who's about
to win solely because they want to keep
control yeah this is how they get you
with the voting for the lesser of two
evils this has been the Ponzi scheme run
on the American people for very long and
then of course you have Dr Oz who was an
early promoter of trans children all the
way back in 2010 and and just back to
the question because I'm really curious
why do you think Donald Trump did this
was it because Sean Hannity was in his
ear or was there something else
happening behind the scenes
yeah no comment I
think I think
I think for whatever reason wants
fetterman to win I think I mean I love
that moment where Tucker Carlson is
doing the handoff with John handy and
he's talking about I think he was
talking about Amazon and Amazon screwing
over the American people and then as
he's handing it off Hannity goes to
private Corporation if they want to
provide a good and people pay for it
they're allowed to do it and Tucker just
does the Tucker face like what what yeah
like that was like a clear split between
the populist new Maga Republican base
which Tucker is is a big proponent of
and a big part of and then the old
corporatist neocon Republican
establishment of Hannity Hannity talks
with Trump probably said you got to go
with us that fetterman wins I don't
think he literally said that he probably
just lied to Trump and Trump was like us
huh okay I'll go with us
I don't think Trump wants fetterman to
win I don't think Trump does I think
handy does
um I think that we have a party outside
you know I'm not talking about Oz I'm
not talking about the race I'm just
saying in general it's something that I
said um the entire time when I was on
the campaign trailer that we have a
um you know um and the Republican Elites
uh they are not as concerned about
winning as you and I may be concerned
about it they are more concerned about
control if the GOP was interested in
winning they would be knocking down my
door trying to get someone like me who
was able to move the needle not just
within Republican conservatives which I
have a strong grasp on but the ability
to walk into any community and and share
our story and move people into our
category we need that kind of energy and
enthusiasm desperately within the
Republican party and if the Republican
GOP the elite the machine within that
was interested in winning they would
have my little brown face all over the
place but they don't because it's not
about winning it's about let's make sure
we control the narrative and we only
have our people and our faces right uh
out there saying what we want them to
say and that is again my heart grieve
because I I don't believe it's hyperbole
we are about to lose our country and I
know most Americans don't think that we
can that that can happen but I believe
we're on the precipice let me pull up
the story from the New York Post to
exemplify what you just said killings in
New York City subway systems Skyrocket
to highest level in 25 years even as
ridership plummeted this is part of an
ongoing Trend we've seen across the
country crime is skyrocketing homicides
are aggravated assaults and robberies
these horrifying stories a woman gets
pushed on the subway tracks a naked dude
running through the subway and if you
saw that people uh in Philadelphia a
woman was raped I was gonna say NP
people just watched it happen filmed it
they didn't just watch it they pulled
out their phone right and that's right
around I'm telling you my kids and I we
every every weekend during the summer we
were on the train from Philadelphia
going into New York and we would spend
the weekend in New York every single
weekend during the summer I have not
been to New York in two years now
because it is crazy
um I mean just case in point in
Philadelphia before the George Soros
backed uh district attorney Larry
krasner came into office there are six
County jails in Philadelphia and they
were at our Max Capacity at capacity is
a little over 8 000 right Larry krasner
George Soros back district attorney
Larry krasner comes into office and
instead of it being at 8 000 he put it
down to I'm around up 5 000 right so
eight thousand minus five thousand
there's three thousand more people who
would General really be in jail
somewhere just in Philadelphia I'm not
talking about all of Pennsylvania just
in the Philadelphia County 3 000 people
who would generally be locked up
somewhere and not up and not out there
on the streets able to impact
law-abiding citizens they're now out
there and when you ask Larry krasner why
are you doing this Larry he says things
like oh I want to do family
reunification right the broken home and
the black family we need to get people
out of jail and put them back home with
the people right but that's three
thousand what part I'm sure there are
some portion of that 3000 who uh who
should not be in this situation is you
know wrong they shouldn't be there but
how many of the three thousand the whole
3 000 or a smaller portion of that three
thousand that is the reason why we have
crime at the rate that it is our our
judicial or judicial system has been
turned into a revolving door they should
put video webcams in prisons for people
because if they should be able to unify
with their family and communicate with
their family everybody should even in
prison in my opinion if you want people
to become better people as a result of
being there and let them do that but if
they're violent criminals I don't put
them back outside the fear of losing the
country is that there's so much violent
crime that the government can't stop it
and then we appeal to private
corporations to bring in private
security and that's the loss then then
we've lost our country then the
corporations are on the show so that's
what I want to avoid this is all
manufactured chaos
manufactured uh uh loss I mean it's just
manufacturing the reason because they
want us to be dependent well it's almost
like there's this very
um massive
you know like a restart happening you
know like a big a big great yes
something different great reset yeah
maybe that one's fine so what they say
is uh what the activists were telling me
back during occupies From the Ashes of
the old we shall build Anew that in
order to build the system they want they
got to knock down the old one this is
this is the idea so you have crime
crushing these cities people are fleeing
them and then you can come in what did
Bill de Blasio say when the when the
property value is tanked he's like now
we can buy them up and create government
housing on the cheap and so so you have
a government that implements policies
that destroys a private real estate
industry then the government comes in
and buys it for pennies on the dollars
to on the dollar to create their
government policy with with new Landing
acquired from the policies that
destroyed them
yep a lot like it except they did it
with guns they didn't even bother
bankruptcy and they're already so rich
and I used to always say to myself you
know running for office again I mean you
know I was at I mean I've had many
careers I'm an author you see my book
back there nothing to lose everything to
gain being black and conservative in
America
um a news commentator work uh military
uh was accepted into officer candidacy
School worked in the financial industry
worked as a adjunct professor of
corporate finance I've had a lot of
different careers in my lifetime um but
right before I decided to get into
politics I was a stay-at-home mom and I
was homeschooling my children we've
always lived in really great school
districts I just believed I could do it
better than what my babies would have
been learning in the school system
especially when they come home and my
daughter is being taught about same-sex
marriage and my son is being taught
about a different family configurations
in third grade I was like I think we can
do this better honey and so we started
homeschooling our kids and so this was
never on my bucket list of things to do
but we need to engage our government and
we need to do it now we need to debate
demand better not from Democrats but
from Republicans because a lot of this
stuff that's going on I don't know if
you guys even know about podesto
Bill Clinton's uh former Chief of Staff
Hillary Clinton yeah exactly right yeah
he is now Biden has now tapped him to to
to
um being his administration to
specifically work in the climate change
yes the almost 400 billion dollars is
now under his hands and what do you
think he's going to do with that this is
a a very a highly political figure he's
going to send this money into different
campaigns and different organizations
that will now I suspect who will now
turn around and donate that money to
these particular campaigns now if I know
that and you know that I'm sure Ted Cruz
and others know that and why are these
people Republicans who see themselves as
president one day not standing up and
shouting us from the rooftop
shells or they just don't realize that
we can recover the carbon and reuse it
out of the atmosphere with the carbon
dioxide just pull the carbon dioxide
because they they want to do electric
grids like Thomas Massey was talking to
Pete booty judge about electric cars
requiring like twice as much electricity
as a refrigerator American's
refrigerator and how by 2030 if everyone
has one electric car how can the grid
handle that and booty judge is like his
response is well it's gonna have to and
Tom's like no no no how will we do it
yeah they don't have an answer you
that's the old Sheamus joke that when
you say okay you want you want good
thing how do you get it they go you want
bad thing well then you want bad thing
if if you question them at any point as
to how they actually will Implement
their utopian Vision they just say
you're a fascist you're rich
and sympathizer right uh listen these
people have a lot of knowledge but they
lack wisdom right I don't think they
have a lot of knowledge or wisdom well
no they lack wisdom they see a hammer
and a male and instead of using it for
its intended purposes they look at a
hammer and nail and say look I found a
doorstop and a key right it just this
isn't how the world worked it's not how
any of this works and yet these people
are now running our country and that is
a fact and all of this is happening if
you want to assume ignorance but it also
could be intentional the reason we have
crime skyrocketing in these cities is
because they want it to happen because
they want the economy to be destroyed
it's because they want to have a great
reset exactly it's either that or they
are some of the most incompetent people
ever and when I listen to Janet Yellen
Janet Yellen is no dummy this is a very
smart woman and when she talks about
transitory inflation I repost it today
an article I wrote in November of 2021
and I was like news flash this ain't
transitional this is going to stay this
is going to be very sticky I spent three
months with our Farmers I was like let
me just start off with the very
beginning of our supply chain and let me
let you hear what farmers are saying
about Fuel and the cost of fuel oil
right now is up 137 percent and I'm like
this is not transitory this is going to
be very sticky this is going to destroy
lives and yet Janet Yellen Jerome Powell
they're all out here talking about
transitory inflation now I have to say
either these these are some of the the
dumbest people who have ever managed to
get their hand on power or they know
exactly what they're doing right I think
they know exactly and these are not dumb
people not all of them maybe Janet
Yellen knows right
knows they are they you know look when
we were talking about this the other
night when Victoria Newland said that
there are biological research facilities
in Ukraine that we're very concerned
about Russia getting their hands on we
want to protect them and then the media
comes out immediately saying bio Labs
don't exist bio Labs don't exist okay
well they know they do they know they're
concerned about them and then we had a
conversation with the guest where he
said there's no biological weapons
research Labs the US isn't doing that
and I'm like it's a semantic argument
it's it's you have these people in the
media in government saying the US does
not do these things and then they go and
do them but then argue semantics about
it so my example was if a guy created a
factory that was building explosives and
someone said this dude's building a
weapons Factory no the explosives are
for Mining and it's like okay those can
be sold off and used as Weapons right
yes okay so we're having a semantic
argument you're making something
dangerous of course in a transitory
inflation is semantic like it's
transitory for now until yeah
it's just another form of transition
it's the meme where they're like first
inflation isn't happening then inflation
uh might be happening but it's not that
big of a deal next inflation is
happening but it's transitory finally
inflation's a good thing here's how it
helps that's what they do coming out I
mean I watched eight hours of the big
banks in America testifying before the
house committee uh the Banking Committee
in the house and it was astounding to me
when they asked a question do you
believe Jerome Powell can can handle and
stop this inflation they all raised
their hand yes yes we agree and then
Jamie dimon Camp comes out right after
that saying the Federal Reserve is my
judge is my judge jury and hangman so of
course if it's something that you that
you alluded to earlier they are
controlled the banks are controlled by
the Federal Reserve they're going to
dance to whatever tune uh Jerome Powell
plays because again as Jamie Diamond
said they are judge jury and hangman so
they're going to do whatever they need
to they're going to say whatever they
need to say and the Federal Reserve is
owned do you know who owns it not not
the people yeah it's a private company
that's basically adherent to the bank
for international settlements in
Switzerland the bank of England the
Federal Reserve of New York and the bank
of Australia like run through this node
the Swiss bank node called the bank for
international settlements I don't know I
think it's the same people that own
BlackRock and State Street that own and
run that thing but it's also behind the
scenes and it there's hasn't yet been
like an audit or oversight it's
intentionally created so that we don't
have oversight over the company well
well the Senate is supposed to have
oversight over
oversight over the Federal Reserve to
clarify their mandates would be one
thing of stabilizing prices uh but the
it yeah so I mean so so they're supposed
to have oversight over them how do you
see the transition of our economy right
now what do you see happening I see like
like the new world order they want to
move to this liberal you know Global one
world at least I do but what do you how
do you see the America
progressing yeah economically I think
we're in and for some really hard days
um I you know when when you hear the
Federal Reserve chair saying I am
committed to destroying demand now
they're talking about demand destruction
that's how they they coin it and when I
was listening to it I heard several
people say on you know on the The
Talking Heads demand destruction demand
destruction I'm like I still have family
who live on that pig farm in Southern
Alabama the farm is no longer operable
but they're very poor and when I hear
demand destruction I immediately see
faces I immediately see who you know who
is going to be destroyed in this process
these people are uberly wealthy this is
not going to impact them very much the
Federal Reserve is the number one reason
why we have income inequality right now
and now they are also creating a lack of
Opera an opportunity Gap right between
those who have and have not that Gap is
is growing growing growing in the first
year of covet of 2020 money our nation
increased the number of millionaires by
30 percent and I'm and I'm talking to
people who were getting pay cuts like 35
pay cuts right and I'm listening to the
media talking about we're all in this
together and yet our nation at one of
the most you know destructive times in
our economy and lives we were growing
the number of millionaires by 30 percent
if you went into covet with a
significant amount of assets it was the
best thing that ever happened to you as
the Federal Reserve specifically began
to shift wealth uh from the people to
certain entities right they are the
number one reason for this wealth Gap
that we have and now we're looking to
the Federal Reserve to fix what the
Federal Reserve broke in the first place
we are going to go to super chats so if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel and share the show with your
friends be the notification you want to
see in the world a lot of people are
mentioning with about a month to go from
the midterms that YouTube is no longer
notifying them that the show is live so
you can bypass the censorship by just
being the notification and sharing the
video yourself so that other people can
see it let's read your super chats we
got Raymond g Stanley Jr who says Kathy
many of us watching vote for you let's
go
well there you go there's another one
too above that looks pretty interesting
which one Nick and Denise go for it read
it uh this is from pubs Maggie Pabst
McGee yeah he says I had to stop
listening to Pink Floyd for timcast IRL
worth it also getting married Saturday
can I get a shout out to Nick and Denise
shout out shout out shout out Abyss mom
says and you homeschooled heck yeah I'm
buying your book ASAP you can be my role
model Ian keep being you what's the
summary of the book
uh it was it's a Clarion call that we
are about to lose our country and we
need to stick our get our head out of
the sand I took um I looked at the black
community as a petri dish of what
happens when Democrats come in and take
absolute control of everything they
leave people broke broken and bruised
and I was sitting out this Clarion
called to the broader American culture
that what has happened in the black
community just looking at what happens
in a community when Democrats have
control of everything is that if we
don't get our head out of the sand what
has happened to the black community is
getting ready to spill out and begin to
impact all of us and now look I mean
what you know every summer what happens
in Chicago that's been happening for
decades now you know 20 black people get
murdered 30 black people get murdered in
one day but you know we all saw it and
some people like oh yeah oh that's so
sad but it happens over there right but
now that has Spilled Out of just inner
city Chicago and that was around around
around the corner of my house and your
house right and that is what the book
was warning about and so my book is
literally reading like prophecy right
now and I am no Prophet but it's not
rocket science to be able to take a look
at what is happening and what is going
to happen if we don't get engaged all
right OMG puppy says Washington's fear
is not an alliance between Russia and
China it's an alliance between Russia
and Europe Zig Brzezinski identified
Ukraine as the key to shattering that
relationship in the grand chess board
CIA 19 1997. yeah it's a big new
Brzezinski he was a part of the CFR
trilateral commission and Bilderberg
Group I actually was able to talk to him
previously before on my YouTube channel
he has since passed away but he was also
the main person who of course set up the
muha hajjin and uh in Afghanistan to
fight the Russians his foreign policy
especially being of the foreign advisor
for Jimmy Carter has set a lot of this
into motion and he has been very
prophetic in a lot of his political
Scholars and and philosophies
interesting Placid Saint says Tulsi only
changed her stance on guns when a
stalker threatened her and she was
denied a permit in her state Hawaii to
get a gun by the very laws she helped
push and support in her State yeah I
mean firearm is the great equalizer yep
it is the great equalizer between me and
someone who's bigger stronger and more
determined to hurt me or my family right
five foot 95 pound woman with a gun is
going to be able to hold her own against
a six foot three 220 pound lean muscle
man who doesn't have a gun in fact even
if he did have a gun she'd still be able
to hold her own yeah training is what it
really comes down to net capacity so
yeah I am all four guns people should
have them vasht says she literally
campaigned on taking away military-style
weapons from people that is our literal
second most important freedom that's
right as Dave Chappelle said second one
there is there in case first it doesn't
work out that's right that's what he
said right exactly yep lizard says I
feel more like we're in pre-war Fallout
uh did you guys did you guys see this
one in August the US government approved
a 100 million dollar contract for the
expansion of Raven Rock you guys know
what Raven Rock is it's the emergency
bunker not too far away from here where
the government's gonna flee to in the
event of a nuclear war now
to better understand this the
construction won't be done until 2027.
but that doesn't mean the reaction isn't
due to the fear of nuclear war right
right if if we got a warning a hurricane
was coming I'd be like we have no
hurricane defense we should probably
invest in that it won't be done till
next year but hey we should start
something right they're also there's
also um
the expansion of Mount weather new a new
building is being put up I think 65 000
square feet Mount weather is another
emergency bunker nearby so the guest
last night mentioned construction going
on at these bunkers and I was like what
so we looked into it yeah 100 million
dollar contract in August for the
expansion of Raven Rock and did the
federal government just buy
um some pills
um potassium iodide oh no no no no no no
uh was it and nipron or something I
forgot the name uh radiation yeah
radiation pills it was proprietary uh
pharmaceutical that the they spent a
bunch of pharmaceuticals it was 295
million dollars I think that's crazy I
totally remember when Trump won in 2016
then the left said when Trump gets in
office we're going to have Wars wars and
rumors of wars no it's happening under
them how about I search to find this
medicine 295 million radioactive
medicine U.S government HHS whatever did
you find it
searching now
check them out yeah 290 million uh
see what it's called which was the drug
and plate end plate there you go like
the letter n and then the word plate all
right none says Tulsi is the ultimate
fair weather fan anti-2a grifter Trojan
Horse spoiler vote Liz Cheney 2.0
angling for an anchor spot on Fox News I
wonder well some people are concerned
that if she runs independent I don't
think she's going to run as an
independent but they think she'll pull
votes away from the Republican she was
very like pro-war in the Middle East for
a while like she was like the Taliban
are evil we must defend our freedoms
they want to take our freedoms away and
I'm like dude that was the narrative
they sold Us in 2001 to get us to go
conquer that's what and that's what
brought about the Muslim ban from Donald
Trump or this this flight band list and
that's so weird because Tulsi on so many
other things I think she's so brilliant
about I don't know I don't know if she
realized something I mean I know she was
serving in the military at that time
Paul thongam says Tim saw your interview
with John Stossel earlier today it was a
great interview keep up the good work
thank you yes they publish that it's
actually fairly old I think it's like a
year old I'm not sure was it 30 year old
yep that was fun though John Stossel was
pretty awesome
Clayton Johnson says nothing like a
World War to keep a civil war from
happening in the U.S one scenario the
elites have more control over the
outcome Patriots are angry no no world
wars do not stop Civil Wars from
happening they give people an
opportunity to create Civil Wars
Yeah
you mentioned this before Russia Russia
uh Spain and World War II great examples
yeah yeah when when the war happens it's
like now's our chance so my fear as as
many people have mentioned China is
going to say oh the uh once the U.S is
directly involved like explicitly
overtly with U.S troops China goes right
for Taiwan knowing we can't do anything
about it I've said that all the time
World War III it's gonna happen anyway I
earnestly believe they China is going to
do a Hong Kong on Taiwan
and instead and I mean it's it's going
to happen and that alone would be
devastating to our economy when you look
at the semiconductors and exactly yeah
Max Reddick says Tim have you considered
having fans on the show you could do a
lottery system once a month they would
share the video there on with friends
and family if you did this you would
blow up fast perhaps but we are
preparing a brick and mortar location a
physical location so what we might do is
some kind of either first come first
serve or Lottery system for members
where you can come to a private Friday
night IRL live so basically what we
might do is with the new space the
Friday Night Show might be in our new uh
a new expanded brick and mortar location
it's where we want to do the Saturday
morning cartoons events bringing
families and their kids to build
community and then Friday night we would
do the show but then on the upper floors
on the lower floor you hang out have
drinks watch the show and then once we
rap we hang out for a little bit
afterwards and so that would be like a
VIP members thing that we got to figure
out how to do it that'd be cool yeah
it's hard to figure out exactly how to
do it for security reasons and how many
you like the occupancy might be like 20
to 40 and so how do people sign up for
it we might just be like first come
first serve here are the tickets go for
it
and then it's like maybe it's going to
be members only but you're still going
to buy a ticket because we got to pay
for the business and everything like
that so we'll figure it out but and then
someone actually said we should do like
a like a a monthly lottery for like
members and I was like sure I don't know
we'll look into that
I had a really good cool idea for for
the business because you know we're
talking about doing this Cafe what I
want to do is I want to put a half craps
table next to the cash register and I
don't know if it's legal but I think it
is what you do is you'd order your food
and drink
and then you would get the opportunity
at no extra cost to roll the craps Dice
and if you get 7 or 11 you win half off
your order wow so it's just like either
you pay half off or you don't and that's
it and it's like a 48.49 point something
percent chance of getting half off your
order so it's purely Promotional and for
fun I think people would would want to
come to us more than anyone else over
the chance to get cheaper coffee in in
bagels or whatever and then I was like
you could we could also do like a
roulette thing or something or like a
blackjack thing how fun would that be
you're like you go in and real quick as
you're paying you're like come on let me
get half off my food you don't win any
money it doesn't cost you any money it's
just it's a free thing so I wonder if
that's legal I think I think it might be
but they might still consider it
gambling or something because you're
buying food or whatever I don't know
I just think it would be fun to be like
you know roll the die you get Aces and
then it's like oh that's it your meal's
free have a nice day
yup I think if if we're basically giving
away the money without you having to put
anything in it might be free like you
can't win money from it well I guess
it's technically winning money
we don't win your money though you can't
lose your money that's it you can't so
maybe that's it you know you're not wage
or anything so it wouldn't be real
gamble right like either you pay for
your food or we give you the food for
free so it's like not really gambling I
don't know we're gonna have skee ball
too that'll be fun skeeball tournaments
that'll be a whole lot of fun we're
gonna we're gonna have video games and
Skee-Ball
sounds like fun yeah
Damien Masters man we got a lot of
people ragging on Tulsi he says Tulsi is
a Democrat plant going to Paul
Republican votes from Trump in the
election so Biden can win again I don't
think Tulsi is running for president did
she announce she was did I miss
something no no
Ryan Brown says Tim if you are willing
to entertain some quack Neo Nostradamus
why don't you actually research the
renzberg prophecies finally they are
over 100 years old and still accurate
geopolitically please take the time and
do it I believe Ian is looking that up
right now rensburg prophecy this sounds
like a job for Shane Cashman
so we're uh we're hoping Shane cashman's
uh new show inverted I think we're I
think it's like it tells the inventor
world live or something like that it's
going to be a live show talking about
this kind of stuff Mysteries predictions
aliens Bigfoot you know and all that
kind of stuff we're hoping to have that
uh ready to go really really soon with
the next couple of weeks so new show I'm
really excited for it a lot of work
going into it we're really excited to
have this uh up and running and then of
course Tales from the inverted world
will keep continuing and it's like it's
like long form and book format and then
we're gonna have a weekly show
discussing all of this Unsolved
Mysteries and creepy weirdness
all right Eggman says people on the
non-left side immediately forget about
grifting the moment someone on the other
side says something they like we are
only making the grifter's jobs easier if
we are that easy to please
I mean you know Ian you brought this up
that Tulsi gabbard made the announcement
she's quitting the Democratic party the
day she launched her new show yeah that
was a probably I'm pre-planned it's got
to be of course publicity stunt but at
the same time it was she's following her
heart I believe
she needs better PR she needed it in the
first time she ran for president too she
just got she went up there was honest
plain straightforward and got
steamrolled because she didn't have like
a manipulation tactic ready to go Brian
mcgannon says watching the episode with
Papa John last year Tim you slimmed down
reminder being healthy is a
revolutionary act now discipline equals
Freedom eat beef and move your body yeah
so uh since then I basically cut sugar
out you know for the most part and I've
brought it back in a little bit but uh
for the most part I avoid sugar I just
have like a lot of fat tons the Stossel
interview was I open it because you
looked swole like I did when I knew you
a year ago I didn't look at you and
think like oh he's got a swollen face
but you mean fat really yeah
but I wonder how it all means like riffs
muscular yeah but I wonder how many
people are living life not realizing how
how fat they are right I was able to see
it and just because I could tell it was
you like a year ago I could just see it
in the interview just looking at it just
you couldn't tell or I could I could
tell
yeah yeah and it was crazy because I was
exercising every day but I was eating
like grains and and bread and stuff and
then I cut all that stuff out now I
basically drink like a gallon of sour
cream every day and all the weight just
comes right off
I'm half kidding about this because you
work out because you escape I was
working out when I when I when I I was
at like 200 when I was skating but fat
and not working out it's not I was
working no no if you were eating the
sour cream and not working out that
wouldn't be good it's because you're
burning the fat it seems I think I think
it's sugar I think it's sugar grains
carbohydrates people overload on that
stuff and it's really really bad yeah
what is this Luke I have so many
comments I'm gonna hold myself back home
broth it's Luke's sitting there eating
at midnight eating bacon and I'm in good
shape too you know I'm not I'm not about
you got a great diet we go out whenever
whenever we're skating Ian's sitting
there I'm not Ian Luke is sitting on the
on the couch with like in his shorts and
no shirt on and he's just like you know
watching I'm getting my vitamin D
vitamin D is important too that's you
know
Ivan Ortiz says Tim is it ethical for
the U.S to draft DACA recipients if they
aren't even allowed to vote but we have
to pay taxes and a subscription to keep
DACA every two years for 500 USD
regarding your last vote
I don't know man all I know is this the
draft says that if you're an
undocumented immigrant you have to sign
up for it
so like you're here in this country
secretly and illegally but you gotta
sign up for military service
don't you dare
yeah so I don't know man I don't know
Wyatt kaldenberg says Kathy I saw you on
Dr Turley your story about your mother
and your birth totally changed my views
on abortion I voted for you you are the
first candidate who changed my mind and
I am old oh
good
all right let's see Raymond g Stanley Jr
says Kathy Miss I live in Harrisburg
I've talked to many black men who think
like us but either don't vote or vote
Dem just cause they vote against what
they're for suggestion on how to change
Minds yeah just have a conversation just
go out and talk to people right I mean I
was a Democrat and then I wasn't and my
strategy is really just walking out and
talking to people black people are not
special Little Unicorns we want what
everyone else want just keep having
conversation with people
right on
rat buttocks excellent Name says Tim I
quit smoking so I could afford a Super
Chat every night right in Pinkerton
2024.
Pinkman who's Pinkerton
be careful when you quit smoking your
testosterone levels go down after doing
so is it because the cigarettes make
your testosterone go up or no there's a
correlation between also eating and uh
you know
getting away from different habits
there's a lot of different reasons oh
because it's an appetite suppressant
when you remove the suppressant you eat
too much and then your testosterone
drops that's one Theory out there yes
all right bran says start fund a new
show awoke and Lefty make it seem like a
safe place for a prominent leftist to
guess to pieron when they show ask hard
questions and expose them would need a
believable host well what we're actually
planning on doing is uh right now on one
of our burners is a crossfire Style Show
now every time I bring this home I'm
like wouldn't it be great if we got like
two different you know political World
Views to have a discussion about
something like calm and rationally with
a moderator everyone's like the left
will never never come on and I'm like
you're right but this is not the kind of
show where we need Hassan [ __ ] it's the
kind of show where we need like an
environmental activist who's working at
a local level and then you get like a
petroleum engineer an environmental
activist to sit down and have a
conversation with a moderator someone
who's checking the news
and I'm like I think that actually would
work really really well and it would
probably uh
I think it would work really well just
simply put it be an excellent uh
business decision people would love to
watch something like that and it would
be good for us culturally to get these
people to have these conversations I
think so I think people are
um almost over the Epic takedown kind of
moments right and we're looking for
something real and authentic and I think
as life gets a little bit more
challenging for people they're going to
be looking for something real people are
going to need hope
yeah I I got the idea because we were
talking about having like a female
skateboarder uh have a conversation with
a trans skateboard who's competing in
female contests and then actually have
them talk to each other about what
they're going through and what their
issues are and then you'd have a
moderator and the goal is not to make it
a debate or angry but to have a
conversation so that people aren't just
talking past each other and I thought
that would be really interesting yeah
but we could do that with a lot of
things like I mentioned environmental
activists petroleum engineer climate
change activist being I've got and
fossil fuels petroleum engineer being
like
or or I mean not not only that someone
who works at power plants or with
electricity being like how many people
are going to die if we do what you want
sure that'll be interesting
all right Zachary Dempsey says can't
tell you how many times I've brought up
a story from IRL while working in a New
York City suburb school to co-workers
and they just refuse to even look into
it for themselves it makes me feel crazy
yeah but you know one thing I would
suggest is you can't go up to someone
and be like hey did you hear X like look
at the story here look it up you've got
to be very subtle and passive with it
like let them talk about their interests
and then you interject something like
yeah you know I was I was I was watching
the thing about Biden the thing about it
I just can't get past the weird you know
they're doing the child sex change thing
but I don't know about whatever yeah you
passively mention these things you don't
need to throw in their face and be like
read these stories read these stories
you know the story so well that you
don't need to reference it to give them
a very subtle shocking statement about
it yeah and then when they're like I I
don't know about that be like yeah I
don't know it was on uh what was it on
it was on some I don't know I saw some
video on Facebook I'll send it to you
later yeah yeah you know and then just
you're you're making sure they're
hearing these things the other thing you
can do that I heard is a really good
idea that or that seems like a great
idea is when someone comes to you and
they're talking about this political
stuff challenge them to not watch any
mainstream news and just read the the
bills themselves
just challenging to do it be like okay
look I don't I don't know about you know
these these these news hubs but why
don't you do this
don't listen to or watch any news
program for say three three days or a
week and then read the bills going
through Congress right and then tell me
what you learned that is exactly what I
do I download and read their bills
invariably people get red pilled because
they're like wait a minute I remember
when I worked for Fusion there was some
Bill about religious freedom or
something and they they everyone at the
company was saying it did X and so I was
like cool we'll put together a story
about it and then we read it and we
couldn't figure out how it did what they
claimed it did I can't remember exactly
what it was they said it was like band
game marriage or something and then I
was just like it doesn't say anything
about that in here and they were like oh
well you know but that's what it does
and then me and this other producer were
like uh
uh I don't I don't understand what we
can even say yeah but they they wanted
us to just say it right yeah I'm like I
gave you it has nothing to say it says
nothing in there about don't say gay but
they right they make it about that
because it helps them it's expedient for
them you know it's weird
Rory F says as far as I'm concerned
there's only one ideal 2024 ticket Trump
cash 2024. maybe Tulsi is having a come
to Jesus moment maybe she'd be Secretary
of Defense I'd be that'd be great you
know that'd be cool cash Patel yeah nice
I tweeted Trump West 2024 yeah and would
vote but but who who am I referring to
Cornell
oh yeah you see I knew that like you
assumed it was Alan West yeah no first I
thought Cornell West I was just like who
are all the west and then you thought
Alan Alan a lot of people thought it was
Kanye and I just thought it was funny
that I could put West and it's like who
is a reference to actually I thought it
was Kanye when I saw the tweet I
actually thought that I'd read it trump
it was Trump West I thought for sure you
were talking about Kanye in the tweet I
tweeted a whole bunch of stuff today
that confused a lot of people but it's
really funny watching everyone just I
like takes like these tweets seriously
when they're obviously not serious but
hey man I have fun on Twitter it's
really good I said uh people who don't
trust the government haven't learned
from history
spicy Loop yep that's a top provoking
one
and then I said something like the
government has you know I I tweeted uh
the government has never done anything
wrong all those bad things that wasn't
real government
all right
guitar escapes is regarding your video I
have a friend who recently swore into
the Air Force and said it was weird that
the oath is to protect your superiors
and not the Constitution country or its
people the oath doesn't even mention
them
really I thought it did is that like a
new thing or is that it's always been in
the Air Force
yeah
Mark shapkot says Tim where to get
long-term emergency food well of course
you know that we when we do our shout
outs it's safe and readymeals.com
that's uh that's what we shout out when
we do
Henry back to play says not only is
Kathy courageous and inspiring she
breaks things down in layman's terms
without missing a beat Bravo
there you go
grafty says meatloaf is much like
graphene if done incorrectly it is much
like graphene if cooked too long buck
buck okay I have no idea what that means
John Hansen says how does ESG not
violate their fiscal responsibility to
their investors how is that legal it's
because they're illegal they're no
longer working with
um what do they call shareholder values
they're going for stakeholder capitalism
so they don't have to make they don't
they're not so concerned with the so
what happens BlackRock doesn't care if
Exxon is making money for its
shareholders it wants BlackRock or wants
Exxon to make money for the the
stakeholders the people that are being
affected by that you're missing the
point you're missing the point that is
illegal and that's the point they're
making the United States maybe it
doesn't matter what these companies
goal is it matters that their goal is
illegal in the United States but they're
not American companies the way they but
they operate in America then it's a
crime but now the way they get away with
it is that you have these um credit
rating companies like MC uh I think it's
mcsi where they essentially say okay
well today you're going to lose money
but we're looking at 20 years 30 years
40 years from now and we are looking
through our crystal ball and a crystal
ball says we're going to have these
particular laws in place and when you
have these laws in place that forbid
fossil fuel now we come back to the
future and say this is the rating where
we're going to give you and so they find
the loophole to say oh this is long-term
investing so you're going to take a hit
today because of these long-term goals
that we have so that's the reason so
that's really how they they offer skate
the illegality of it fat chipmunk says
GOP leadership is trying to sabotage
legit candidates they can't control they
revoked all their funds from Blake
Masters recently absolutely that's what
they did I don't know I don't know about
Blake Masters but I can tell you who in
my race again it's day it's it's what I
what I said before what I will continue
to say is that we have you know I mean
when you're in the family you know when
I'm talking to my children my husband
and I are talking to our kids we say
listen when we're out here on the street
mama got your back I'm gonna be right
there for you but when we come home it's
going to be a different story right I'm
gonna take you to task and it's the same
way within the Republican Party in the
family we got some issues to contend
with and we need to start cleaning house
we have a group within the Republican
party that has nothing I mean they're
probably Democrats if anything but
they're definitely a una party and their
goals do not match our goal and they're
sabotaging conservatives
also he says I agree with Serge I
watched the interview this morning and I
immediately knew it was an old interview
by how much rounder your face was it
threw me initially oh my goodness I
tried
all right zieker Fender says three three
cheers for Kathy Barnett she's right on
with the fed's policy of reducing demand
we get the inflation and lose the jobs
and the nuclear Holocaust well they get
their billionaire bunkers they got them
in New Zealand you saw the reports about
how they're building these these exotic
Resorts out in the middle of nowhere
they got Mountain bunkers they're
building missile silo Bonkers property
in my my uh in Montana and Wyoming and
Idaho skyrocketing and now they've got
these big 100 million dollar contracts
over at Raven Rock somebody knows
something and they're getting ready for
something and they ain't telling us but
uh if you listen to this show at least
you won't be 10 steps behind only two so
maybe you can pick up emergency food or
something and uh I don't know man get
some chickens
yeah I have a plan with your neighbors
you know talk to your neighbors talk
about worst case scenario have
contingencies planned you know who's
going to have where's the water where's
the food going to be I'm people you
trust obviously all right everybody if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel and share this show with your
friends become a member over at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only show coming up for you at about 11
pm so you don't want to miss it you can
follow the show at timcastirl you can
follow me personally at timcast Kathy do
you want to shout anything out yes uh
please go um to Amazon wherever books
are sold purchase my book read it buy
one for a friend holidays are coming up
give it to them and let's try to Red
Pill some other people please go to my
website at kathybarnett.com I've started
a new organization called be better
America it is going to be funded by you
but the same things that I have always
been doing I'm going to continue to do
which is pushing our values so please
consider donating at Kathy Barnett dot
com Kathy thank you so much for coming
on that was a very great conversation I
think I know why Trump uh did what he
did but I'm going to tell you after the
show anyway my YouTube channel is
youtube.com forward slash we are change
I did a very interesting video today
about musk Ukraine the crazy statement
by the former Joint Chiefs of Staff I
got into all of it youtube.com forward
slash we are change that video is up for
you right now see you there thanks Luke
thanks Kathy great to see you great to
meet you good conversation ma'am yes and
I know you're a woman but I called your
man anyway you know woman I'm in despite
I thought it was a man yeah look I know
what it means to be a woman
thanks thanks for being cool Serge
what's up dog hey guys uh thanks very
much for the podcast I really appreciate
it Kathy it was a great one um better
than yesterday I would say a little
weird one yesterday but uh it was great
thank you for coming I'm serge.com
everywhere I'm pretty sure you can find
me there thanks take away time before we
go I have a sad announcement to make for
everybody and uh we wanted to wait until
the very end uh a couple nights ago
Roberto Jr's mom Katarina died in her
sleep we don't know exactly what
happened or how and we had Katarina
brought to a vet for I believe it's
called the necropsy I think they're
trying to determine the cause of death
because Katarina the chicken was uh only
about uh just just shy of three years
old
and so that's very young for a chicken
she was sleeping in the normal position
didn't really show any signs that that
we noticed of distress or sickness and
uh the next day she just didn't wake up
and so that's uh Roberto Jr's mom so
it's been really tough on him if you
have any uh comments questions or
concerns if there's anything you are
wondering about chicken City you can
email Roberto Jr timcast.com and he will
respond to your messages and uh we'll
figure something out it is sad because
uh Katarina is one of the original
chickens that we got for chicken City
and you know is the mom of Roberto Jr
and a bunch of other babies that that
eventually oh a couple other that were
hatched so uh is it Roberto Jr or
Roberta Jr all one word Jr uh I'm
assuming it's JR all right well you
email both just in case and you'll get
through to one yeah and uh but but he
but he does respond to all of his fans
so Roberto Jr is he's a good host all
right everybody thanks for hanging out
we'll see you all over at timcast.com in
about an hour or so again thanks for
hanging out cheers everyone